first they said don't buy masks now they
say wear a mask so here's a quick guide
to making your own masks at home because
the government clearly doesn't have a
clue and it's all on us now thanks to
the Baltimore aerial surveillance
program for these overhead shots that's
some seriously dystopian [ __ ] cut your
fabric into two six by ten inch
rectangles looks like six inches there
when you measure imagine you're
redrawing your own congressional
district to give yourself some extra
room for any stupid mistakes these
things are sharp so be careful we've got
enough tiny prick screwing things up
right now thread the needle like a
Clinton on gay rights fold like
Republicans on free trade and hem right
down the line like way too many votes in
the Senate Republicans I know you guys
love closing borders so this part should
really tickle your nuts use string
fabric or elastic to make ties for your
head politicians will need a little
extra to get around that thick empty
skull so there you have it the Joe Biden
of face masks I don't want it it might
touch your face in a strange way I doubt
it could even do the job but the only
alternative seems dangerous and
irresponsible yet if I even consider a
third option somehow that makes me the
[ __ ]
[Music]